the country where the corona virus
pandemic began is bringing back strict
measures to control a new outbreak China
has locked down at least 29 communities
in Beijing where officials confirm
dozens of new cases after seeing almost
none in that area for nearly two months
widespread testing is also underway in
the region
ramie Inocencio shows us how the Chinese
government is now preparing for the
worst
this wholesale food market is China's
newest epicenter in its battle against
coronavirus the size of more than 250
football fields the Shin fadi market
claims to be the biggest in Asia and
supplies up to 80 percent of the
capital's meat and vegetables
authorities moved quickly putting up
barricades around the market and
isolating neighborhoods with infected
people health officials are now
launching a massive testing campaign
targeting all the markets workers recent
visitors and anyone they came in contact
with that's up to 200-thousand people on
top of the 90,000 residents living
nearby now at least as many people are
on lockdown across the city of more than
22 million massive housing blocks under
quarantine with food deliveries going no
further than perimeter road blocks I'd
be lying if I said I wasn't worried said
this woman right now there aren't many
people on the subway there aren't as
many as before it's all reminiscent of
the unprecedented lockdown of Wuhan and
central China from January where an
estimated 35 million people were
impacted after the world's first
coronavirus outbreak was identified at
another food market China's chief
epidemiologist Wu Jun yo says the next
few days will be critical to
understanding how the virus spreads it
may also help us understand what
happened in the whoo-hah that
environment particularly the cold
weight environment may able to keep
survivors survival for long time Beijing
officials are now barring residents from
high-risk areas from leaving the capital
flights are still extremely limited and
health checks are the norm at all
airports and railway stations and
new surge isn't just happening in
China's capital it's also happening here
in Japan's capital to Tokyo has reported
more than 20 new front of our spaces
every single day for nearly the past
week for CBS this morning
rainy Inocencio Tokyo thanks ramie we
got to pay attention because we may be
done with Corona but Corona is not done
with us in this country too so we're
paying attention